divide each of the following quantities
into the ratio that's given in the
record right you need to pay very close
attention to this because this is quite
tricky people get a dump roll all the
time so let's write down the important
information first
what is it turning 70 it was a kilos and
they want to divide it in this ratio
okay
watch carefully here's my first step I
want to do it in four to five four five
so therefore how many parts are there in
total if there are four parts yup and
five parts here the total number of
parts is 4 plus 5 is 9
there will be nine parts in totally ok
sir how big is each of the parts if
there are nine of them like well
literally right one part is equal to
yeah there are nine pots terms to the
Cure's how big how many kilos is each
pot and I think if you divide childress
semi-colons by nine you get 30 kilos
right check it out just to be sure I
think we're okay but you can check it
yourself just so you know I'm not ready
all right okay now if there's one pot
there I want four parts to five parts so
what are there will be four of these
four parts that's four times thirty
kilos right
what's four times eight hundred twenty
good okay
that's the full part one the five parts
will be 150 right but I'll just write
down where that 150 comes from it's five
times thirty kilos okay that's a hundred
and fifty kilograms okay you check it
does it work a hundred twenty plus 150
yes it adds up to something
okay so then your final answer is 120
kilograms and a hundred and fifty units
they go yeah excellent okay let me
rehearse all the steps so that you are
so you can see how I did it okay okay
all right where does this come from
it is the important part let's start
from you've got this amount you want to
buy it it up like this so the very first
thing I did was say if I want to go in
four to five then the total number of
pieces like there's four here one two
three four and then there'll be five he
one two three four five right so now
there's nine in total right so your
first step is how many total parts
second step then work out how much one
part is and that was how I divided I got
my 30 and then the rest falls out from
okay so a vitally important sitting out
like this okay see how I know it's a lot
too quiet but it makes it really clear
what all the numbers meet rather than
just you know where did this come from I
don't know it works but what yeah oh
yeah yes that's right that's right if
I've done it like say one to six right
I'd say well there's one pot over here
and then there's one two three four five
six parts so there would be seven in
total
so yes you add them that's that's four
plus five that's right yes